can you give an overview of what open
air codecs and github co-pilot is
how it works
and why the hell it works so well
so with gpd3 we noticed that the system
you know that system training all the
language out there started having some
rudimentary coding capabilities so we're
able to ask it you know to
implement addition function between two
numbers and indeed it can write python
or javascript code for that and then we
thought
we might as well just go full steam
ahead and try to create a system that is
actually good
at what we are doing every day ourselves
which is programming
we optimize models
for proficiency in coding we actually
even created models that both have a
comprehension of language
and code
and codex is api for these models so
it's first pre-trained on language
and then
i don't know if you can say fine-tuned
because there's a lot of code
but it's language and code it's language
and code
it's also optimized for various things
like let's say low latency and so on
codex is the api that's similar to gpd3
we expect that there will be
proliferation of the potential products
that can use coding capabilities and i
can
i can speak about it in a second
compilot is a first product
and developed by github so as we're
building uh models we wanted to make
sure that these models are useful
and we work together with github on
building the first product co-pilot is
actually as you code it suggests you
code completions and we have seen in the
past there like a various tools that can
suggest how to like a few characters of
the code or the line of code the the
thing about copilot is it can generate
10 lines of code you
it's often the way how it works is you
often write in the comment what you want
to happen because
people in comments they describe what
happens next so
um these days when i code instead of
going to google to search uh for the
appropriate code to solve my problem i
say oh
for this array could you smooth it and
then you know it imports some
appropriate libraries and say it uses
numpy convolution or so i that i was not
even aware that exists and he does the
appropriate thing
um
so you you write a comment maybe the
header of a function and it completes
the function
of course you don't know what is the
space of all the possible
small programs it can generate
what are the failure cases how many edge
cases how many subtle
errors there are how many big errors
there are it's hard to know but the fact
that it works at all on in a large
number of cases is incredible it's like
a
it's a kind of search engine
into code that's been written on the
internet
correct so for instance when you search
things online then usually you get to
the
some particular
case like if you go to stackoverflow
people describe that one particular
situation
and then they seek for a solution but in
case of uh co-pilot it's aware of your
entire context and in context is oh
these are the libraries that they are
using that's the set of the variables
that is initialized and on the spot it
can actually tell you what to do so the
interesting thing is
and we think that the compiled is one
possible product using codex but there
is a place for many more so
internally we tried out you know to
create other fun products so it turns
out that a lot of tools out there
let's say google calendar or microsoft
word or so they all have uh internal api
to build plugins around them
so there is a way in the sophisticated
way to control calendar
or microsoft word today if you want
if you want more complicated behaviors
from these programs you have to add a
new button for every behavior
but it is possible to use codex and
tell for instance to calendar
could you schedule an appointment with
blacks
next week after 2 p.m and eat the right
corresponding piece of code
and that's the thing that actually you
want so interesting so
what you figure out is there's a lot of
programs with which you can interact
through code
and so there you can generate that code
from natural language
that's fascinating and that's somewhat
like also closest to
what was the promise of siri or alexa
yeah so previously all these behaviors
they were had
hard-coded yeah and it seems that codex
on the fly can pick up the api of let's
say given software yeah and then it can
turn the language into use of this api
so without hard coding you can find it
can translate to machine language
correct it to uh so for example this
would be really exciting for me like for
um adobe products like
photoshop uh which is the i think
actionscript i think there's a scripting
language that communicates with them
same with premiere and you could imagine
that that allows event to
do coding by voice on your phone
so for instance in the past okay as of
today i'm not editing word documents on
my phone because it's just the keyboard
is too small but if i would be able to
tell uh
to my phone you know
make the header large then move the
paragraphs around and it does actually
what i want
so i can tell you one more cool thing or
even how i'm thinking about codex
so if you look actually at the evolution
of uh
of computers
we started with very primitive
interfaces which is a punch card and
punch card essentially
you make a holes in the
in the plastic card to indicate zeros
and ones
and
during that time there was a small
number of specialists who were able to
use computers and by the way people even
suspected that there is no need for many
more people to use computers
um but then we moved from punch cards to
at first assembly then c and these
programming languages they were slightly
higher level they allowed many more
people to code and they also
led to more of a proliferation of
technology
and
you know further on there was a jump to
say from c plus plus to java and python
and every time it has happened
more people are able to code and we
build more technology and it's even you
know
hard to imagine now if someone will tell
you that you should write code in
assembly instead of let's say python or
or java or javascript and um codex is
yet another step toward kind of bringing
computers closer to humans such that you
communicate with a computer with your
own language
rather than with a specialized language
and uh i think that it will lead to
an increase of number of people who can
code
yeah and then and the kind of
technologies that those people will
create this
it's innumerable it could you know it
could be a huge number of technologies
we're not predicting at all because
that's less and less requirement of uh
having a technical mind
a programming mind you're now opening it
to the world of
other kinds of minds creative minds
artistic minds all that kind of stuff i
would like for instance biologists who
work on dna to be able to program and
not need to spend a lot of time
learning it and i i believe that's a
good thing to the word and i would
actually add out that so at the moment
i'm a managing codex team and also
language team and i believe that there
is like a plenty of brilliant people out
there
and they should apply
oh okay yeah awesome so what's the
language in the codexes so those are
kind of
they're overlapping teams so it's like
gpt the raw language and then the
codex is like applied to programming
correct and they are quite intertwined
there are many more teams involved
making these uh
models
extremely efficient and deployable okay
for instance there are people who are
working to you know
make our data centers uh amazing or
there are people who work on pro putting
these models into production
or uh
or even pushing it at the very limit of
the scale
um
so all aspects from from the
infrastructure to the actual machine
learning so i'm just saying there are
multiple teams while the
and the team working on codex and
language uh i guess i'm i'm directly
managing them i would like i would love
to hire them if you're interested in
machine learning
this is probably one of the most
exciting uh problems and like systems to
be working on because it's actually it's
it's pretty cool like what what uh the
program synthesis like generating of
programs is very interesting very
interesting problem that has echoes of
reasoning and intelligence in it
and i think there's a lot of fundamental
questions that you might be able to
sneak
uh
sneak up to by generating programs yeah
that one more exciting thing about the
programs is that so i said that the
um you know the in case of language that
one of the troubles is even evaluating
language so when the things are made up
you you need somehow
either a human
to say that this doesn't make sense or
so in case of program there is this one
extra level that we can actually execute
programs and see what they evaluate to
so that process might be somewhat
more automated in in order to improve
the uh qualities of generations and
that's fascinating so like the wow
that's really interesting so so for the
language the you know the simulation to
actually execute it that's a human mind
yeah for programs there is a there is a
computer on which you can evaluate it
wow
that's a
brilliant little
insight
that the thing compiles and runs
that's first
and second you can evaluate on a like do
automated unit testing
and in some sense
it seems to me that we will be able to
make a tremendous progress you know
we are in the paradigm that there is
way more data and there is like a
transcription of millions of uh of uh
software engineers yeah
yeah
so
i mean you just me because i was going
to ask you about reliability the thing
about programs is you don't know if
they're going to
like a program that's controlling a
nuclear power plant has to be very
reliable so i wouldn't start with
controlling nuclear power plant can i be
one day but that that's not actually
that's not on the current road map
that's not that's step one and you know
it's the russian thing you just want to
go to the most powerful destructive
thing right away
run by javascript but i gotcha so it's a
lower impact but nevertheless what
you're making me realize
it is possible to achieve some levels of
reliability by doing testing
and i thought you could imagine that
them you know maybe there are ways for a
model to
write even code for testing itself and
so on and there exists a ways to create
the feedback loops that the model could
keep on improving
by writing programs that generate tests
for the instance for instance
and that's how we get consciousness
because it's metacompression that's what
you're gonna write that's the comment
that's the prompt that generates
consciousness
compressor of compressors you just write
that
do you think the code that generates
consciousness would be simple
so
let's see i mean ultimately the core
idea behind will be simple but there
will be also decent amount of
engineering
um
involved like in some sense
it seems that you know spreading these
models on many machines
and it's not that trivial yeah and
we find all sorts of innovations that
make our models more efficient
i believe that
first models
that i guess are conscious are like a
truly intelligent they will have all
sorts of
tricks
but then again there's uh
which is certain argument that maybe the
tricks are temporary thing yeah they
might be temporary things and in some
sense it's also even important
to
to
note that even the cost of a trick so
sometimes people are eager to put the
trick while forgetting that there is a
cost of maintenance
or like a long-term cost long-term cost
or maintenance or maybe even uh
flexibility of code to actually
implement new ideas so even if you have
something that gives you 2x
but it requires you know 1000 lines of
code i'm not sure if it's actually worth
it so in some sense you know if it's
five lines of code and 2x i would take
it
and and we we we see many of this but
also you know that requires some level
of
i guess lack of attachment to code that
we are willing to remove it
you